the jurogan experience dude there's this
uh couple that's getting divorced and
they have
600 million dollars worth of art it is
the biggest single art collection that's
ever going up for auction and there's
one painting that they have on the wall
that is a 2007 painting by some person
i've never heard of i obviously don't
know much about uh modern art in
particular and it's worth i think 40 to
60 million dollars that's it
40 yeah 40 60 million bucks it's a
[ __ ] splatter you know what that
looks like wow that looks like a good
pussy's background
yes look at this it says sai tuambi's
untitled work from 2007 has an estimate
of 40 to 60 million courtesy of
sotheby's what in the [ __ ] are you
talking about could you imagine 40 to 60
million dollars is an insane house on a
massive piece of land isn't it able
this is like the original nfts guys come
on but this is so crazy like for 40 60
million dollars you should have a
[ __ ] insane house a private jet a
ferrari a mercedes a crazy game room i
would have just assumed
movie theater it's a good toilet you
should have some [ __ ]
and a one that painted nothing else
would be nice
i mean [ __ ] imagine just imagine that
that's worth 60 million dollars
please don't look at any of the other
images i just want to concentrate on the
other one jimmy i don't know what that
is that's pinocchio the other one is
pinocchio's head they found pinocchio
skeletons scroll down is that true look
at that i didn't know that it's worth a
billion dollars
the whole thing is so insane that
painting is so insanely bad does anyone
try to explain why it's good does
anybody try to say i can make that
see i cannot i don't know why it's good
because it's a huge canvas that's it's
all about how big the canvas is that
doesn't make any sense there's no
there's no sense to this there's zero
sense to that being worth 40 to 60
million dollars i don't give a [ __ ] who
made it i don't give a [ __ ] where he's
from where he went to school who who he
mentored under [ __ ] you eat [ __ ] that's
not 40 million i don't know i could see
even worth 35 million but i see that
worth 3 500
it's worth 3 500 bucks
steve martin would be able to tell you
if it's good or not is he a art that's
his big thing
yeah yeah but this doesn't matter this
is only worth what people are willing to
pay for it and i guess some people are
willing to pay for it because this
gentleman tai twambi
is uh apparently a very famous artist
which i get okay that's fine but there's
no way i can do that like the whole art
thing is such a bizarre status thing i
was at an agent's house once in in
aspen's amazing house and uh i was over
this guy's house like wow this house is
crazy like how much the agents make
all those things shady robbing people
yeah and i'm in his house and i see this
thing that's framed it's like this big
and it's like tissue paper and like
color and i go i go is this like
something his kid made
and he goes
no that's a ball
that's thirty thousand dollars i
remember going what the [ __ ] are you
talking about is that it dude you know
the same artist that did that buddy of
mine is similar a lot of these guys
exactly like what a kid does my 11 year
old can [ __ ] that up she can do so much
better than that dude my friends and
artists who started out you know a lot
of them saw those graffiti people
in like in new york like uh boss gal was
one of those like graffiti people that
became out so my buddies i didn't
realize how much his stuff went for
like he offered me a painting and i was
like i just wanted one and i was like i
think it was worth like 30 grand when i
looked up
i couldn't believe it 30 grand yeah i
he's a good artist i mean he's a really
good artist but i i was shocked at like
what the art world
look at this one jamie that i just sent
you
and tell me how much you think this
one's worth this is tell me
how much is it worth just i just want
let's see if kurt and i can uh see who's
better at guessing let's take a wild
guess okay i'm gonna that's very
good under boob drawing there and some
good hip actually i don't say it's worth
a lot that looks like an art school
sketch pad from uh art institute where i
went to ten million dollars how much do
you think it's worth kurt
i don't
that looks like somebody's sketch to me
from what i don't think
i think like 30 dollars 30 10 million 10
million my 11 year old made that
oh i'll give them
so this is this is how crazy it is
she's very talented no it is actually an
11 year old girl who drew that off the
top of her head but that's not watches
on a thing that's why i knew it wasn't
going to be worth it but it's still even
like that kind of sketch with the right
artist is probably worth a preposterous
amount of money how old is your house
she's 11. she might have been 10 when
she made that she might have been 10
when she made that she's really talented
i don't like that said that but imagine
that imagine that you like that splatter
show that other image before which is
probably worth like 50 million bucks
how much is that worth
sotheby's how much is that worth
well please tell us
this [ __ ] guy that is is that tai
twan he's dead i was trying to find his
own oh he's dead that's why yeah ty's
dead what's that 20 million that
scribble
that was psy see why
yeah look what he wrote look at it
imagine making a living doing that like
you go my husband's an amazing artist
wow that's cool i bet you his name has a
lot because first of all that's a very
good name psy twembly that seems like a
catchy art name this has been explained
to me by friends that are artists this
is what happens when you
bring your stuff to a gallery and then a
big time collector buys it
someone who comes in and goes i i want
this is amazing and this is this
incredible new artist his name is sai
twombly he's incredible and then this
this one person who's in the know
decides that it's good and then other
people start buying your stuff too and
then it becomes more valuable because
you only have so many pieces and if
they're big pieces like big huge pieces
yeah even though it looks like dog [ __ ]
it's worth even more yeah it's like
that's why that piece is worth 40 to 60
million dollars just it spawned a lot of
people in la to be are probably other
places too where i know a couple of
artists but they have no train they just
scribble like that but they're not going
to be
you never know
well i guess
what's their name do they have a cool
name like i don't want to say
what the [ __ ] is that like it's a side
twimly oh it must be like a bit yeah
immediately if it's a kurt metzger
people are going to go it's not yeah it
doesn't have the same right side
is an amazing scribble name it's not a
bad scribble name yeah but it's like
that stuff's not good like objectively
it's gotta be the last thing you buy
with all your money i mean you would
think once you have your stuff then you
go i have so much money left there's
people that are like these hedge fund
[ __ ] that are worth just billions and
billions of dollars of nonsense money
they're moving money around and they're
making money
and don't they have like a place some
airport where it's all
where they stack it yeah it was in that
movie um
you know what's the time travel movie
that uh born in america it's intended
they rob
they rob that vault where they keep
really expensive
kind of paintings like saudi princes
keep so nobody sees them they're just in
this vault i guess at some airport
but in tenet i think that was a real
place they were where rich people keep
their art watch the entire episode for
free only on spotify